for the for the men okay
do you think it's confusing for men when
they don't know how many dates they have
to take a girl on to get sex
no no
there was the only time i've been told
about like this date like like you don't
think it's confusing how what does that
mean the same is it the same object like
let me tell you for real
so
men that meet someone they'll have sex
at any point like
but when they say like oh five five date
like or whatever
they're gonna go to them five days and
then act the same that they would have
had like beforehand so it doesn't matter
how like you how long you put it out for
blah blah blah blah blah
it's like
that's i i i respect again more if like
you're like i'm gonna have sex with you
cool like and then from there i'm gonna
like
treat you okay no i've just i've just
was thinking of double standards and
like because you guys kind of exchange
your resources in exchange for like sex
at some point
right would you agree or disagree
like men in general uh yeah i've heard
i've heard it kind of been said like
that before
carry on
read it whatever that is read it
yeah i've heard him said like that
before i guess the resources i'm men of
is more fun so i've just i've just heard
like men get confused because they're
like well like they never know how long
they have to wait and like so like no i
think people are different like there's
gonna be people out there that i'll
probably you know be like oh probably
need to wait for the third day that i
don't need to do that that's quite
old-school ways is it
as women i'm not i'm not like oh he has
to take me out on five dates or like six
days i don't know is that is that even a
woman like you would have sex like if
you felt like that everything was good
though what you would have sex on the
first date because you're like you feel
like having sex on the first date yeah
is that a thing anymore and maybe i'm a
bit older then um like oh we have to
have this many days it is definitely a
thing that's a question to you pearl
how many dates do you need to smash
bro
um
my last boyfriend we were dating so like
how many dates did you take down i don't
oh gosh that was a different situation
but do you have a number on you no it's
not a number because it kind of depends
where i met you like yeah because for me
like it takes me a second to feel like
comfortable i guess so it's like if i
met you
through like mutual friends it'd
probably take less time than if i met
you on like an app because i have to
make sure you're not going to kill me
you know
yeah so but as a young girl do you have
a number in your head i just want to
know how the dating like no
for me i'm not do you have a number in
your head no because basically i've been
in a six year relationship so i'm not
really in the day and i don't really
know how it works in the date good for
you
i feel like when i was younger it was
like oh yeah we like because all these
rules that you used to hear but it's
just like
i'm a big advocate on maybe not the show
but like with your friends and your
girlfriends you should talk about your
sex life right what happens what pops up
and i would never know that though
this is why i think you should because
the only
aspect of sex that we get is porn and
porn isn't real so if i don't speak to
my fellow friends or girlfriends or
teammates effectively like like
personally fed like okay like you tell
your boy or your girl how great your sex
life was like boom boom boom
girlfriend oh yeah no i'm talking about
your no i'm friends like your closest
friends whatever right so like they they
hear about every how everything is great
but i had my best friend i was never
like i was like never thought this would
happen i'm in america like never
he moves to my girl only because of like
what he's heard how how did that's what
i'm saying now bro that's it that's what
happens on the right no girl man
but unless you happen this weekend i'm
trying to tell you that like
as in someone i'm trying to no that [ __ ]
happens for a while
i just feel like that person wasn't your
friend because me personally i talk
about the my sex because she's my she's
my friend outside of here right and i
talk to her about my sex life like on a
regular occasion yes then because then
you know what's healthy you know what
yeah i had i had a friend who was
getting choked right okay cool that's
sexy but she was going to a point where
she was like passing out but she didn't
exactly you're laughing at that but she
didn't she's young right this is my like
freshman sophomore year in college she
didn't she don't know but if she don't
have this safe space conversation where
you say actually babe you know what that
this is that's sexy and that can happen
but this is too far but if you saw that
in porn which is
oh [ __ ] when she passed out like five
times what the [ __ ] is going to say who
says it's too far but she thinks that it
it's okay like okay maybe that's wait
wait it's not too far for you she likes
yeah she does she doesn't that's what
i'm saying i'm saying as of the open
conversation she said but she didn't
know it was no other option like she
just thought that was the only thing and
that's why i'm saying having the
conversation she didn't know that an
option of not doing
was like an option
going too far i'm saying
i thought she might like it she said
nothing so
she didn't like she didn't she didn't
say she didn't like it she said nothing
but that's only in her head so if you
have these open conversations you you
guys don't you
you have the pride thing because now
you're saying if i like passing out i
will tell someone yo do not [ __ ] make
me pass out bro i'll be like yo like do
this do that like but she said
six months i mean like oh my god like i
don't actually like this because you're
a man no sick
it's not the same can i ask you
something okay cool say that's your
sister you don't know about that's it
hear me hear me just hear it
here's my question just hear my question
because i want to give you a different
point of view yeah yeah i'm gonna say
your point of view is wrong but i'm
thinking i'm giving you a different
perspective that's your sister see she's
getting choked by her her partner and
she's passing out do you think that's
okay from your perspective could you
have seen it in a perspective where
you're choking
okay cool you're taking your girl to the
point she's passing out but she's
it might not even be a safe thing she
might not even know especially
wait wait if this i said she was young
she's a sophomore she's a rookie right
if this is your first sexual
relationship and you're with a guy it
could be the other way around right i'm
gonna tell her like quite like she's
gonna believe me as i'm older like i'm
like this is what i'm saying you're
saying well how do you know she doesn't
like it because it's her only
her only experience
like that's the only days like i'm just
saying
what i'm saying has grown women even it
doesn't even happen
i'm just saying wait wait wait wait
don't wait wait i'm saying it doesn't
even have to be bad stuff it could be
new stuff that you haven't tried and
then you bring it to the table like yo
you did what okay i'm gonna try it with
my man so it doesn't necessarily have to
be negative stuff of choking or whatever
but it might be you've never been choked
and you're like bringing it to the table
you guys said girls are going to talk to
each other
i have a question i have a question for
the guys do you feel like guys share
more what they do with their friends
about girls that are more casual and
share less with their friends about
girls that they're serious about
so you're saying guys don't talk you
don't no neither of you know anything
about each other's sex life no yeah oh
no it would be what you said like if
it's
it was like the
uh
outsides of non-relationships like we
used to talk all the time but i would
never like sarah like chat to him about
what me and my girl yeah
and then he's been on the back end
relationship like we don't like oh what
do you do last night like it's different
but i smell like with the random ass or
like we have a party or whatever but we
talk about them like not about us we
talk about like how they behave like
because really intriguing like
this is what i'm saying like really and
truly
if i was ever going to go on a date with
a girl that i took seriously i will
never tell my mandom about that i'll be
like this because like this is my
feelings it's my life because
this is a gender difference because
women value relationships more and we
bond like like we i mean i feel like
half the women raising girls bond is
like we talk about guys
that's what we're doing
but but but like like for and the same
thing with what you're talking about
with like she couldn't say no because
women tend to be more agreeable than men
like that we were standard deviations
also she doesn't know any better well
yeah but so that's what i'm saying if
you have these open conversations
but no but i'm saying like like this is
a gender difference what we're talking
about here because he's saying well why
wouldn't you just say something
because that that's a man's response
like if a man doesn't like something
he's going to say
no but but it's not like
women are more aggressive
like conflict as much as men
so men are more direct and that's a
gender difference
like so that's that's like that's why
when you you're talking right now you're
like i don't i don't get it why don't
you just say something no i do i'm not
all the girls kind of understand like
what you're talking about yeah yeah
right right i'm just saying most things
should be brought to the table of
different
fun bad good left right what you like
because the porn side of things have
affected especially men okay yes women
watch porn but men have indulged in it
and it skewed your mind of numbing it